hey what's up you conspiracy theorists
right-wing maniacs and other assorted
bad people
i'm the chief bad guy dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message and
today is july 13th in the year 2021
as always
subscribe
tap the notification bell see what
happens legally i have to say it uh we
got four stories for you and man
i wish we had journalists in america i
am not a journalist i am but a humble
man who puts on a jacket in the morning
sits down in my office and tells you
what i think
uh which apparently is journalism these
days because we don't have journalists
that will actually tell you anything
true we have a political class that lies
to you about everything a media class
that then launders their lives and then
it leaves people like me who would have
rather been in the nba trying to tell
you something that's true so today's
just like a litany of lie show
first off uh bill hb3 in texas is the
new texas voting bill you know we've had
these uh voting bills in florida and in
georgia now in texas a couple other
states that the democrats are saying are
an affront to democracy and we're trying
to stop you know black people from
voting and poor people promoting and
it's an assault on everything we hold
dear and all that stuff well i'm
actually going to read you what's in
this texas voting bill and then we're
going to show you some of the lies that
jen
saki is saying about it and chuck
schumer is saying about it and they're
just lying they're just absolutely lying
about everything speaking of lying then
story number two uh joe biden uh who
again i can't confirm he has dementia we
now call it ops he has uh old person
syndrome
he's gonna be working with the phone
carriers
to possibly send you sms messages if
you're texting
misinformation about kovid
really yeah really bizarre right like
are they going to be reading your text
messages what will count as
misinformation i'm fairly certain if
orange man had been reading people's
text messages and then sending
government information that people might
have been against it say the aclu some
of our civil liberties organizations
might not have been happy about orange
man reading your text but
now ops biden's doing it so it's all
okay uh and then finally the third story
which i just thought this was absolutely
hilarious
is that major league baseball now i
forgot to watch baseball i stopped
watching baseball in around 1994 as don
mattingly still on the yankees i don't
know um but
uh
major league baseball is investing about
150 million dollars to get more black
people to play baseball uh because you
know sports has to be hyper-racialized
like everything else we're going to
compare some numbers related to the
general population and how many white
people play baseball and hispanic people
of black people and we're going to
compare that to the nba and see if
really the big problem is in america is
that there aren't enough black people
playing professional baseball
oh give me the strength here we go all
right so this texas voting bill this is
really just bananas so i'm going to
start
by showing you some of the lies now you
know that white house press secretary
jan saki this woman is an extraordinary
liar she she should get an award i don't
know do they give out an award for like
greatest liar like she should get the
greatest liar award maybe you know i
have a friend who does ceramics and
maybe we can put together a little sign
because this woman i want to mail it to
the white house she just cannot say
anything true as i always say if if you
asked her what her favorite color was
she would say for like the woman is
completely incapable of saying anything
that's true and the new thing that all
the democrats are doing is lying about
all of these voter
laws that are happening in these red
states which mostly are about having an
id
to vote that's mostly what they're about
but i'm going to read you the actual
bullet points and tell you what it
really is about but here's sake on
what's going on in texas right now he'll
also decry efforts to strip the right to
vote as authoritarian and anti-american
as a and stand up against the notion
that politicians should be allowed to
choose their voters or to subvert our
system by replacing independent election
authorities with partisan ones and he
will highlight the work of the
administration against this the
necessity of passing the for the people
act and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act and how we need to work
together with civil rights organizations
to build as broad a turnout and voter
education system to overcome the worst
challenge to our democracy since the
civil war
the worst challenge to our democracy
since the civil war i guess they forgot
about that january 6th insurrection that
they said was the worst thing since the
civil war and they completely forgot
about 9 11 and everything else i mean
these people are absolutely ridiculous
uh the the top line there nobody is
stripping the right to vote so she's
saying that in essence you know the
republicans are stripping the right to
vote from people do you think there's
any republican is there any mainstream
conservative republican
anyone in america that does not want
legal citizens to vote have you heard
anyone say that have you heard we're
going to strip
the right to vote from legal citizens
nobody is saying that but that's what
they say over and over now before i get
to the specifics that are in the bill
the specifics that they never mention by
the way and if if uh you know what's his
name over at fox who's the fox reporter
that's usually in there ducey right
peter ducey who i think is a fine
reporter uh peter ducey if you're if
you're watching this by chance maybe you
want to ask in tomorrow's press
conference hey jen can you give me the
specific
thing the specific quote in the bill
that is the thing that is an effort to
strip the right to vote etc etc like
because if it's really all about ids
then we can have an interesting debate
about ids again you have to show id to
go mini golfing right you have to show
id to get a beer and go on a plane
but it's not just gen saki that's lying
they all lie endlessly here's chuck
schumer this morning
in a democracy
no right is more sacred than the right
to vote and yet across the country
republican-controlled state legislatures
are conducting the most sweeping and
coordinated attack on voting rights in
generations
fueled by donald trump's insidious big
lie that the election was stolen
republican legislatures are not only
making it harder to vote they're making
it easier to steal an election actually
believe that
donald trump does the big lie
everyone knows it's a lie
and now republican legislatures are
acting on that big lion saying we could
steal an election what is happening to
our democracy
what is happening to our democracy
you're quite right chuck schumer you are
happening to our democracy and you are a
liar and we know you're a liar and you
know that we know you're a liar and you
keep lying uh he says that these attacks
these are a sweeping and coordinated
attack on
voting rights so okay
i thought dave
that's pretty that's pretty intense to
say something like that a sweeping
attack on voting rights so you know what
we're going to read you some bullet
points about what is actually in hb3
this texas
voting law we've got some quotes here
from the national review i believe there
are nine bullet points and then we'll
jump in and unpack the legislation
pushes back against what we're supposed
to be temporary expedience during the
pandemic such as drive-through voting
and 24-hour early voting marathon so i'm
going to just comment on each one very
quickly as we go through this so okay so
first off what they're saying is they're
pushing back on some of the things that
we had to do because of covid so things
that we always did and then we changed
some of it because of cobit so so far no
we're not
sweeping taking away anything okay so
that's number one number two it
explicitly forbids election officials
implementing practices not contemplated
under the state's election statutes as
sometimes happened during the pandemic
okay so meaning election officials
aren't allowed to do things that they're
not allowed to do okay under the
pandemic i guess some stuff happened i
don't even know exactly what happened
but i have no doubt that there were some
hijinks right but basically they're
saying we have statutes on how we run
elections and you're gonna have to stick
to those statutes all right we're two
for two uh three in many counties it
will extend the daily minimum time for
having early voting by one hour
early voting i thought everybody loves
early voting we're extending early
voting okay pretty good that's three
four in certain circumstances employers
are required to give employees time off
to go vote my god this is evil this is
just extraordinarily evil next one
among other things it would require
voters to write a driver's license
number or other identifier on absentee
ballots matching the existing voter id
requirement for registering to vote and
voting in person okay so if you've got
an id a driver's license or some other
id we're just going to have some ability
to prove that you are you
racist
then it would ban public officials from
sending out unsolicited mail-in ballots
a common sense provision to keep excess
ballots from floating around so this was
one of the things during covert people
were just sending out ballots all over
the place i got several ballots here
it's just a way of trying to control the
amount of ballots going out not saying
don't send ballots to certain people
right but we're not going to have
partisan people just send out a
gajillion ballots
next it would mandate that all voting
systems have a paper trail on or before
2026 with a funding incentive for
counties to comply early
a paper trail well that would be pretty
good because you know we're used to
ipads and touch screens and you kind of
press things and does anything really
happen so a paper trail is a little
printer that's in the machine that
allows you to know afterwards because
you have a physical thing a piece of
paper with it's been printed on that
shows you that the vote actually counted
and then finally for sizable
jurisdictions that can easily pull it
off it would require live streaming of
voting counting proceedings so that
sounds pretty good so then everybody
votes people show ids we make sure
everyone followed the policies etc etc
and then using this thing that came out
about 20 years ago a webcam we're going
to stick a little logitech webcam up in
the corner and we're going to make sure
that people aren't you know taking big
pieces of paper and moving them here and
shifting them here and changing things
and all sorts of stuff
guys did any of that did any of that
seem like a sweeping assault on voter
rights did any of that
seem like an assault on democracy did
any of that seem like the greatest
attack
since the civil war or whatever nonsense
that crazy woman just said but these are
the people we are dealing with they
don't
mind lying about everything because they
know the media is not going to do
anything they know they simply will no
it's not that they won't do anything
they will propagate and promulgate
that's your word of the day they will
promulgate that lie okay now i thought
it was interesting because you know the
same people who are telling you that you
can't
ask people to have ids for voting
because that's somehow racist or that
people in the middle of the country
can't get to xerox machines and black
people don't know how to get online or
you know they also don't know how to get
an accountant or a money manager or some
such nonsense
they're the same people who want
everyone to be vaccinated but
i was thinking about it and it's like
well if you want everyone to be
vaccinated you'd i suppose need proof
that everybody was vaccinated right
because you can't just say okay everyone
get vaccinated and we're just going to
take your word for it right i mean
there's no honor system in america this
is america 2021 there's no honor uh so
let's pull up the vaccine card this is a
sample vaccine card that people get when
they get vaccinated and it's
extraordinary
but as you can see on the vaccine card
they ask for your name and some other
information your date of birth and stuff
like that and then you know a certain
amount of people that want you to be
vaccinated and want the government to
mandate the vaccine they want you to
carry that card around so you can show
it at a store and when you get on an
airline and everywhere else so i think
you see the hypocrisy the lunacy here
they're just incredible liars i i don't
even know how to describe this in any
other way and it's such a freaking shame
and and such a dereliction of duty by
these clowns at cnn and msnbc and
everywhere else that and and base and
everywhere washington post new york
times i mean you guys know all of it
right like i don't even have to name the
places but think about it there are
people wandering around because they are
brainwashed and i feel bad for them at
some level they are brainwashed by blue
and on conspiracy theories right i mean
chuck schumer there talking about
trump's big lie it's like chuck schumer
you know you guys were all pretending
that trump was a tool of of russia for
four years and that the election was
illegitimate hillary clinton still has a
tweet up saying that the 2016 election
was illegitimate that donald trump was
an illegitimate president so they lie
and then they accuse everyone else of
lying so as you can see guys like
there's nothing wrong with these bills
making sure that we follow the policies
that are in place which is basically
what's there making sure that there's a
paper trail on the votes and that you
are the actual person who says that you
are when you vote and that we're going
to watch
the people counting the ballots like
that's all legit that's all legit and
they're lying and i think the best thing
that any of us can do
is you've got to push back on this
because they're the liars they're
calling us the liars and you've got to
show your friends like show your friends
this clip and let your friends tell you
that i'm a liar and that i just made up
all of this stuff and then you can do a
little research and find out what's in
these bills we're not making this up
right there is nothing in there that
says we're gonna try to make sure black
people can't vote and we're going to try
to make sure that poor people can't vote
or anything else they're actually trying
to tighten up things so that we have
more
um belief
right like so that we have more belief
in the electoral system which many of us
have a very shaken belief on at this
point all right i think you get it uh
but if you don't think that the
government is that bad and that the
representatives are uh you know great
people if you think that they're really
great people well then why would they be
spying on us but that's the new thing
that they're going to be doing or i
suppose what is old is new again um
we've got a quote here from fox news on
monday politico reported plans from the
biden administration to battle
misinformation in regards to the covet
19 vaccine the white house has decided
to hit back harder on misinformation and
scare tactics after republican lawmakers
and conservative activists pledged to
fight the administration's stated plans
to go door to door to increase
vaccination rates political road the
pushback will include directly calling
out social media platforms and
conservative news shows that promote
such tactics biden allied groups
including the democratic national
committee are also planning to engage
fact checkers more aggressively and work
with sms carriers to dispel
misinformation about vaccines that is
sent over social media and text messages
okay so this is quite
extraordinary did you catch that part
about sms carriers that's the phone
carriers that's at t that's t-mobile
sprint do they exist anymore that's
verizon okay what they are saying
is that if you send a text message to a
friend or to a family member or to
whoever
and it includes whatever they deem as
misinformation that somehow
you're gonna get a message on your phone
from the government and that's going to
be in cahoots with the democratic
national committee like what is going on
here and who's going to decide what
misinformation is and as we know over
the last year and a half they tell us
one thing one day and one and then
something else the next day so they're
gonna have to be correcting themselves
constantly um but this does seem a
little bit like spying right like if uh
if you're you know private citizen
and you text your brother some
information whether the government likes
that information or not what right does
the government have to read that private
communication between the two of you and
then send you messages like this is the
worst sort of authoritarian stuff that
governments can do and they're doing it
right here and i by the way i once again
want to
want to clap and congratulate for my
good
liberal
friends my you know the 10 non-woke
liberals who still remain like bill
maher and the usual suspects who always
you know complain about woke-ism
complain about all the problems of the
left but then vote these people in you
always vote these people in and here
they are ushering in all of the worst
anti-liberal things
possible so this is deeply dangerous
look we know that the government spies
on us right like there's that famous
moment from a couple years ago when
under oath uh cia director james clapper
that he was asked if
the i believe it was the nsa was spying
on americans and he goes like this
scratching the top said he goes not
wittingly and of course you may remember
that episode of seinfeld where they talk
about when you're lying how you touch
your face right so if it's a little lie
you touch down here and if it's a bigger
lie you touch up here and if it's a big
lie up here and he was like scratching
the top of his head like a monkey so it
was an absolute lie so he lied under
oath and then you know what happened to
him not only nothing he got a job as a
cnn analyst because that's what happens
in this ridiculous swamp of nonsense um
so this is this is dangerous stuff like
they're going to be reading your text
messages and by the way you're allowed
to have opinions of things on things
you're allowed to have opinions on
whatever political thing
or medical thing or anything else as a
private citizen well i think you're
allowed to or at least the way it was
set up you're supposed to be allowed to
i guess i guess not much longer in in
biden's america
but you're allowed to share
misinformation
i mean that's just the truth that's
that's what the first amendment's all
about you're allowed to have an opinion
you're allowed to share thoughts you're
allowed to share correct thoughts and
incorrect thoughts and everything else
and the idea that the government is now
going to be jumping in reading your text
messages sending you messages
what else are they going to do like
they're going to so it also said that
they were going to work with social
media companies so now are these social
media companies tools of the government
so if the social media companies now
ban anybody or block anybody or whatever
blow up people's accounts well is that
now a direct assault on the first
amendment which says that the government
can't infringe on speech right like
that's been the whole the whole argument
about social media has been that these
are private companies whether that's
true or not that these are private
companies they can do whatever they want
well okay now that we know that the
government is going to try to work with
them to stop the spread of
misinformation that kind of sounds like
the government would be infringing on
your first amendment so
lawyers lawyer up because uh this ain't
getting any better all right the third
story just because it's so freaking
bananas and shows you how stupid the
endless racialization of everything is i
had to do this story uh major league
baseball america's past time people it
is going to invest 150 million dollars
to ensure that more black people play
baseball we've got some quotes from espn
which used to be a pretty decent sports
network i don't even know exactly what
it is right now except a 24-hour race
palooza network major league baseball is
committing up to 150 million dollars to
the players alliance a non-profit
organization formed last year and
composed of active and former major
league players aiming to build more
equitable systems in baseball and
increase black representation throughout
the sport according to a monday news
release beginning in 2023 mlb will
provide an annual 10 million plus an
additional 5 million in matching
contributions from external players
alliance fundraising it represents the
largest financial commitment in mlb
history towards the goal of improving
diversity in sport on the field in
managerial coaching positions and in
front office leadership so okay before
we get to breaking down uh some of the
stats related to how many white people
and black people and hispanic people
play baseball or basketball or anything
else which is just so stupid in and of
itself before we do that i just want to
say something about sports in general
nobody cares what color you are in
sports except this new hyper-racialized
woke set of people i have played
basketball my whole life i've played
baseball
i've watched sports my whole life as you
know i don't watch any current sports
anymore i watch old sports but when
you're playing a sport and when you care
about sport whether it's track and field
whether it's basketball whether it's
swimming
sports are the great equalizers it's the
ultimate meritocracy nobody cares if
you're a great athlete everybody loves
you
right like if you're a great athlete and
the best at what you do and you try the
hardest and play the hardest and you win
it's like nobody's running around caring
about race nobody cared that magic
johnson was black and larry bird was
white if anything it was sort of fun
there was a there was a sort of funness
between this white guy from indiana and
magic johnson showtime la right like
nobody cares nobody cares except these
people so now let's just break down some
numbers uh right now so in the major
league baseball by race
57.5 of the players are white
31.9 percent of the players are hispanic
7.7
are black and 2.9 percent are asian so
that's that's pretty interesting and
then i said to my guys well let's get
some numbers i don't know what the
racial breakdown of america is because i
don't really care about this stuff so i
said let's get the racial breakdown
of america and compare it to these
numbers so in america 60
of the people in america are white now
57.5 of the major league baseball
players are white so actually white
people are underrepresented in major
league baseball so i assume that
somebody's going to start a non-profit
to up that to 2.5 right we got to get
that 57.5 we got to up that 2.5
get that to 60 so that white people are
exactly 60
in society and exactly 60
in baseball because that's equity and
yeah okay hispanic people man they are
crushing it in major league baseball
31.9 percent of major league baseball
players are hispanic but only 18 of
americans are hispanic so hispanics are
overrepresented by about 13
in baseball we've got to get rid of them
the same way we got rid of asian people
at harvard we must get rid of hispanic
baseball players
now i know the media matters people
that's the clip you guys are gonna go
for enjoy it there you go you losers uh
black people okay so this is the
interesting one black people 7.7 percent
of major league baseball players are
black
13 percent of americans so it's off by
you know a little less than six percent
about five and a half percent or so
right now
okay so black people are slightly
underrepresented does that seem like a
major problem does that seem is
somebody stopping black people from
playing baseball do black people
generally like basketball more i don't
know that's a general thought
but nobody's stopping them literally
nobody's stopping them like is there a
young kid who is a great young black
baseball player who is like crushing it
right and then the coaches and the
league is like ah we don't want any more
black people in this league like it's
just sheer nonsense and then asians
slash other so i don't know who
qualifies as other
uh are at 2.9
now uh i thought we'd jump over to the
nba because basketball is my favorite
sport as you know and and if baseball
has a racial problem then i i would
suspect that basketball would have an
even bigger racial problem uh so white
people make up only
16.9 percent of nba players now white
people are 60 percent of america do the
math people we got a big
big problem we got about a 43 percentage
point problem over there we've got to
get more white people in the nba i'm
going to show you a video of me on the
basketball court in just a moment
because it's time my dreams are about to
come true it's very exciting hispanics
are only 2.2
of the nba but they're 18
of uh of all of america now they were
oprah represented in baseball so we'll
just that's a wash okay we'll just let
that be and this one's a doozy this
one's tough black people
74.2 of the nba are black and uh 13
of uh america is black so they got about
a 61 percentage point difference there
so we've got to lower the amount of
black people in the name of equity we're
going to have to we'll just randomly
select them
you know it's it's what we have to do
and then other is 6.3 percent against
again i don't know who other are now all
right this is very exciting for a guy
like me because i often you know i've
got a basketball above me and i love
playing basketball and uh you may know a
former guest and friend of mine i
believe he's the the most appeared on
guest of the reuben report of all time
is dr gadsad up in canada uh gad is a
professor at concordia university uh he
just wrote a spectacular book had him on
maybe six months ago or so called the
parasitic mind he's been battling wokism
his whole life he has an incredible
life story grew up in lebanon during the
lebanese war his parents were kidnapped
by palestinian terrorists he eventually
moved to canada as a thriving wonderful
life and he's just a great guy well gad
sad
posted this video this short video of
him playing basketball this is a
lebanese immigrant to canada a
brown-skinned lebanese immigrant to
canada playing basketball and he called
me out on twitter yesterday take a look
hey reuben you want some of this you're
looking for some of this action
you want some of this
you want some
all right now when dave rubin
okay when dave rubin gets called out
on twitter on a basketball court dave
rubin does not lay there and take it you
know what dave rubin does dave rubin
does this
challenge accepted sad
oh come on now
oh he's stuck he's hot
come on
flip-flops people i was in flip-flops
okay 45 years old torn acl in the left
knee wearing flip-flops one take right
there so the challenge is on gad said
you bring it but the point is um i am
going to send this video uh directly to
nba commissioner adam silver who's very
woke by the way you know he had the
black lives matter logo on the court
last season then they took it off this
season because the ratings kept tanking
and they realized that the their own
base basically didn't like it so i guess
they solved racism they took black lives
matter logo off um but i'm gonna send
that video and i demand in the name of
equity to be in the nba next season i
know that the finals are about to wrap
up but as a 46 year old with the torn
acl which i just got prp that's when
they spin your blood and they inject
your plasma back into my knees feeling
pretty good i have basketball shoes so
i'm not going to get out there playing
flip-flops this is not you know i'm not
making a joke here obviously but i will
be in the nba next season and you know
then we'll have a free and fair and just
society
i feel like we should play the looney
tunes theme song to end this show
part one of my interview with kevin
mccarthy uh senate leader for the
republicans we did it right here in
studio is up right now on youtube and of
course it's up ad free and early at
reubenreport.locals.com
and as i keep saying there's a lot going
on on the locals front so i got a bit of
a hectic day today but i hope you
enjoyed the show as always i hope you
smiled a little bit people always say
two things that i really like they say
dave the show keeps me sane and i
laughed and like to me if i if i can do
that while giving you a little bit of
news and a little bit of information
then i've done my job so i hope you
enjoyed the show and i will see you
tomorrow